if you play stupid games you will win
stupid prizes if you encourage
sexual deviants big hairy husky dudes
who put on skimpy little women's outfits
and stiletto heels and they have a real
strange interest in jiggling around for
little kids
i think probably you're gonna you're
gonna wind up with guys who have a
sexual interest in little kids that's
what's gonna happen it's not just on the
weird sex stuff that this rule holds
true it holds true ever there's a video
that was going viral yesterday it's
about a poor bodega worker jose alba
he's a 61 year old bodega worker
he was in new york i believe and he was
attacked by a career criminal the career
criminal's name is austin simon austin
simon this big hulking dude walks behind
toward this
somewhat elderly
bodega owner
goes behind the counter starts pushing
him around won't let him get up won't
let him move and then they get into a
scrap the the
big
career criminal guy's girlfriend
apparently stabs the bodega owner and
that or the bodega worker rather and
then the bodega worker stabs the big
hulking guy to death
we we actually have the clip of this so
we have security camera footage which is
really really important because of how
corrupt our criminal justice system has
become
take a look at this if you're listening
right now i will narrate it for you you
see this big hulking dude wearing what
is apparently a very expensive t-shirt
and he pushes the bodega guy this older
guy
who's
smaller he's older
apparently they got into a fight because
this criminal's girlfriend didn't have
75 cents and so the bodega guy said well
you can't if you don't have the money
you can't buy the the product so this
guy goes behind the counter starts
pushing him around
really gets up in his face and the
bodega guy he's just he's just kind of
sitting there he's trying to get he's
trying to walk away but the criminal
won't let him get away the criminal
starts really beating him up now the
bodega guy starts bleeding
it's not good and then it now we're off
camera at this point apparently the
girlfriend i guess had already stabbed
the bodega guy at this point it's a
little unclear because you're off camera
next thing you know though
this what the criminal didn't count on
was the bodega guy grabs a knife and
stabs the criminal
so the criminal goes down
the bodega guy is bloodied but he's
holding a knife now and he's taken down
this thug
who was pushing him around and trying to
steal his stuff and not even letting him
retreat the bodega is trying to leave
he's he's trying to extricate himself
from the situation the criminal won't
let him do it guess who gets charged
with a crime
guess who get you know you know the
answer because of the state of our of
the state of our justice system so
there's a racial element here the
criminal is a black guy and the bodega
guy is hispanic i guess with a name like
jose alba
but hispanics are borderline white these
days and so you've got this racial
element at play
and then you've got
what's even more at play here in new
york you've got a preference for
criminals and a a disadvantage for
victims
there's no way you can watch that video
and say that the bodega guy isn't is the
aggressor
there's no you can watch that video and
say that this criminal is the victim and
when i say criminal by the way this
guy's got a rap sheet a mile long this
guy was already out on parole for
assaulting a cop at the time of this
deadly encounter he has at the very
least eight prior arrests for assault
for robbery for assault during a
domestic dispute on and on those are
just the ones that we know about
and so what happens the poor bodega guy
who's defending himself gets arrested
and the manhattan district attorney
alvin bragg who is entirely pro-criminal
and anti-victim he's throwing him in the
can with a sky-high bail the the bail
for this bodega guy is a quarter million
dollars you think bodega guys have a
quarter million dollars lying around i
don't
and by the way the da wanted a higher
bail the d.a wanted a 500 000 bail
but the court lowered it to quarter
million dollars it won't matter there's
no way the bodega guy's gonna pay it
there is nothing compassionate about
what these people are doing
what the the d.a and the courts and this
corrupt justice system they they think
they're being compassionate or at least
they say they're being compassionate oh
these poor criminals we have to feel bad
for the criminals ignore the victims
ignore the guys getting pushed around
and threatened and attacked we just have
to feel really bad i gosh can you
imagine how society must have failed
what's his name austin simon oh that
darn society
making him commit at least eight prior
crimes and then attack this bodega guy
and then and then in an act of
self-defense the bodega guy stabs him
because austin simon played very stupid
games and got into a fight and attacked
a man over
a bag of potato chips over 75 cents
and lost his life because i do feel bad
for austin simon i don't feel bad for
him in the sense that i don't think that
this bodega guy should be thrown in
prison or charged with any crime
bodega guy was completely completely
justified i feel bad for austin simon
because
he's an idiot and i feel bad for austin
simon because of the way that i feel bad
for all criminals they've gone down a
bad path they are harming not only
society but they're harming themselves
socrates wrote about this or well plato
wrote about this in the voice of
socrates that we really should pity
criminals because they're harming
themselves as they injure other people
they're really injuring themselves
they're injuring their own souls
and then this guy winds up dead in a
bodega
because he played stupid games and he
had to win stupid prizes furthermore
though
if this d.a
if this court if this criminal justice
system
were tougher on criminals
fewer austin simons would end up dead if
this guy austin simon didn't think that
he could just walk into a bodega and
because of political correctness and
because of intersectionality and because
of soft on crime policies he could just
do whatever he wants steal whatever he
wants push whoever he wants around and
nothing's going to happen and if if
anyone tries to arrest him the cop is
going to be the one who gets lambasted
in the media not the criminal if he
didn't think that he could go in there
and harm people and commit crimes with
impunity
he'd be less likely to do it and he'd be
less likely to end up dead
it's not compatible i think
we would have a much safer society and
we would have many fewer needless deaths
if
there were more jose alba's in the world
stabbing people when they are attacked
they're good on jose alba the guy not
only should not be arrested not only
should not be charged with a crime the
guy should be given a medal for public
service because not only did he defend
himself which is his right
but he is sending a message to other
criminals don't do it don't do it guys
it's not worth it it's not worth it for
the bag of potato chips or the candy bar
or the bottle of soda or the 75 cents
your life even your life even you
degenerate criminals who are
wreaking havoc on society even your
lives your mostly miserable lives are
worth more than 75 cents
but unfortunately
that's not what the what the authorities
are doing the authorities are
encouraging more stupid games you play
stupid games you win stupid prizes i'm
going to play you two clips back to back
from lori lightfoot the eccentric mayor
of chicago lori lightfoot is very upset
over the intense harsh toxic political
rhetoric so i'm going to tell you what
she said a few days ago
and then what she said a couple weeks
before that
the toxicity
in our public discourse is a thing that
i think we should all be concerned about
right and it's ironic obviously they
were having this conversation and what
happened on independence day you know
we're not like a lot of other countries
where
the independence their version of
independence day is marked with you know
true troops and tanks and no what we do
in the united states is we come together
as a community
he said thank you
clarence
[Applause]
so i guess we had to bleep it out but
she says f clarence thomas f him and
that's and we need less toxic rhetoric
we need to cool down the rhetoric you
effing clarence thomas nazi racist uh
evil you well hey guess what if you want
less toxic discourse
you're you're probably going to need to
engage in less toxic discourse and you
don't want to do that you're obviously
being disingenuous when you complain
about the discourse so that's fine but
just know
when you do it when you play those
stupid games you will get you will in
fact get
stupid prizes
right now go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knowles podcast you are probably
getting pinched right now at the gas
tank at the grocery store whatever you
are paying for the price is going up
with one exception if you hear my call
with one exception
that would be pure talk you can save a
ton of money on your cell phone pure
talk gives you talk text plenty of data
for 30 bucks a month
30 but no price increase there we're
talking about a major price decrease i
am a pure talk customer they have the
most reliable network in america the 5g
coverage is great they're veteran owned
they've got a customer service team
right here in the usa so you will be
able to understand them when you call
them stop giving your money away to
verizon at t and t-mobile switch over to
my guys over at puretalk they make it
super easy there is a no risk money-back
guarantee go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter promo code knowles podcast to
save 50 an additional 50
off your first month switch over to pure
talk service in less than 10 minutes
that is promo code knowles podcast canon
w l e s p o d c a s t all one word at
puretalk.com
mr knowles thank you for taking my
question and thank you puretalk for
making it possible
in the aftermath of the overturning of a
row secular women everywhere have
threatened chastity and an end to hookup
culture
if you can even imagine such a world you
know this would render apps like tinder
bumble and the like obsolete
we are all excited about what the daily
wire is doing not only to rebut
left-wing pop culture but give the right
a pop culture all its own my question is
this
is it time for the daily wire to start a
conservative dating app
my name ideas include swipe right with a
capital r
the d wire
or my favorite maga matches with an
optional paid upgrade to ultra mega
matches
i do expect royalties what do you think
you deserve royalties you probably won't
get them but you deserve royalties for
that
i i love the idea because i want more of
you people write in all the time you're
single you want to meet people but you
don't want to date some squishy libs so
you don't know what to do and you you
know i think it would be great it would
be a wonderful thing if we could set up
our wonderful daily wire members and
listeners
but there is a structural problem and
you alluded to it in the first part of
your question which is
dating apps have an incentive to keep
people dating
they don't have an incentive to get
people married
and the only way they have an incentive
to get people married is in as much as
people who want to get married will sign
up for the app to then
ideally get married so it has a kind of
attraction in that way but if you want
consistent customers then you need
people to stay on the apps which means
you've got to discourage marriage and
encourage the hookup culture
so it would be a very difficult needle
to thread i'm not saying it would be
impossible but it would be
it would very likely become
self-undermining if you had a
conservative dating app that was
strictly meant for marriage unless you
could incentivize the company to
incentivize people to get married i
don't know maybe you have to pay a dowry
to the company if you get married or
something like that we'll have to look
into it then we can use part of those
dowries to pay you your your royalties
i'm glad you like that clip guys i am so
close to 1 million youtube subscribers
and you know what's going to happen
i'm going to get a million youtube's not
going to be happy about that they're
probably going to completely nuke my
account well bring it on baby that's
what i say i'm an accelerationist when
it comes to youtube please subscribe
ring the bell
send this to your friends text it email
it carrier pigeon we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you